hello everyone and welcome I hope you
can see my slides
um welcome to my talk about data
visualization and storytelling or data
storytelling through visualization
um first a little bit about me my name
is Marisha I am a data scientist and
data science educator at go data driven
company in the Netherlands and I'm also
an organizer for the Amsterdam chapter
of biodata and besides that I'm also a
hobbyist Storyteller whether that's on
stage or through writing I love stories
and I used to think that this was a
hobby that I had that was very different
from my technical day-to-day program
programming job as a data scientist
but I learned that that may not be the
case and that's what brings me here to
you today
because data visualization something
that is very common in my day-to-day
work can also be a form of Storytelling
just to get a couple of details uh out
of the way I want to make some things
clear first of all what is talking not
is not going to be about it is not going
to be about data visualization for data
analysis you know the type of data
visualization you do to get insights
from your data sets before you do any
modeling you probably got that covered
it is also not going to be about what
the best deploying library is in Python
in fact all the figures and graphs I
make for this presentation I simply used
basic muscle lip and the things we'll be
talking about today are about data
visualization as a whole more restricted
to any tooling
of course you wonder what will this talk
be about well first of all I'm going to
try to convince you why data
visualizations can tell the story
and second of all I'm going to show you
some simple steps of how your
visualization can tell the story that
you want to tell
foreign
so let's start at the beginning why do
we bother visualizing data to begin with
some people are of the impression that
charts are simply pretty pictures while
all the important information can be
gathered through statistical analysis
unaffective and often used tool to
demonstrate that visually visualizing
your data is in fact important are these
four figures here these are data sets
that unscums quartets it's a set of four
data sets where each data set produces
the exact same summary statistics that
means the main standard deviation and
correlation
uh which could lead one to believe that
the data sets are quite similar but it
turns out that if you visualize them
they lead to very different
visualizations and these data sets are
clearly not the same
so let's say that we have a data set we
have an X and A Y coordinates
we have some summary statistics because
we have the values but your question is
does that tell you everything about the
data that you want to know in this case
does it have any added benefits to also
make a plot of the data
well in this case
it actually does because we see that if
we plot the X and Y coordinates it
represents a dinosaur and this data set
is a dinosaur and this data set was
created by Albert kaido and urges you to
never trust summary statistics alone
always visualize your data
this point is even further emphasized in
the article same stats different graphs
where the authors created 13 distinct
data sets with the same summary
statistics so that's the X and the y
mean the X and Y standard deviation the
Pearson's correlation
two decimal places whereas you can see
that these are actually drastically
different in appearance
so we know visualization matters but you
probably know that you've probably also
made some visualizations yourself
so the question is what does that have
to do with data storytelling
well
first of all there are different types
of data visualizations
we have a visualization like this one
which is a simple scatter plot of nine
data points made with multiple lip and
this is made just like our dinosaur plot
to get a little bit more insight into
the data at hand
thank you
but that's a very different type of data
visualization than the one that we see
on the right here where we have a data
visualization that visualizes the number
of deaths per month in Iraq from 2004
until 2011.
but whereas one is a simple plot
intended for data analysis the other one
the one on the right is clearly designed
to incite some kind of emotion the title
the color the orientation of the bars
they all contribute to the message
you don't even have to see or read the
exact numbers that it represents to know
what this visualization is probably
trying to tell you
and just as easily that message can be
flipped as well the data visualized here
on the right is identical to the one on
the left but because the data was
presented in a different way it also
guides you to a very different
conclusion
and that's why we typically make a
distinction between two types of data
visualization the first chart that we
saw the simple model of the Scatter
Plots is an example of exploratory data
visualization
that's what we do when we as individuals
are looking for insights hidden in our
data we form hypothesis for instance is
the customer satisfaction going up over
time and we check these hypotheses by
visualizing our data
and this is what we do when we're
looking for whatever is noteworthy or
interesting about our data or hidden
gems in the data so to say
but the second type of data
visualization is what we call
explanatory data visualization
and this is the type of visualization
that you make when you want to
communicate the Insight that you found
by exploring your data with someone else
an audience most likely not a data
scientist
that doesn't immediately need to be a
fancy infographic like the one we just
said before but where exploratory data
visualization is
experimentation explanatory data
visualization is there to communicate an
insight
and it also means that the best
exploratory visualization is not
necessarily the best explanatory
visualization
because when you're exploring your data
you have the luxury of time you can look
at summary statistics create different
visualizations spend some time
dissecting the information on the graph
presented to you and make connections to
insights that you gathered before so
when you're communicating your insights
you do not have that luxury of time if
you're presenting to a stakeholder you
cannot take them through that whole
process that led you to your inside it
should be as clear as possible from the
get-go
so
exploratory visualizations tell a story
maybe your analysis revealed that the
recent changes to the marketing you've
made campaign made people look more
favorably towards your company and
therefore you recommend continuing this
or you've discovered that chickens grow
best on a certain diet therefore you
recommend this diet
there's often a point explanatory
visualizations aren't just there to be
pretty or to prove that you did some
work as a data scientists they are there
to support a point that you're making or
start a conversation
because data is only valuable if given
context and while data itself might be
objective every decision you make 100
it shapes a different story
look at this chart for example it shows
the population growth over time over the
last 60 years
and we see that there's quite a bit of
growth there it looks a bit worrying
but this graph looks critical
the both line charts come from the exact
same data sets but a tiny decision like
the amount of he or she display as a
reference have a huge impact on the
story The Chart tells and our role as a
data Storyteller is to bridge the gap
between clinical and analytical data and
the story that we want to tell from the
data the context
foreign
so how can we tell a story with our data
like I said I'm a hobbyist Storyteller
and when we think about stories there
are three main points
um and it's not beginning middle or end
it is the context in which the story
takes place the people or the characters
in there and what their motivation or
purpose is
and although our story of our data does
not feature people are places
um we can have similar elements in our
data source and these are the three apps
first of all the foundation of the
visualization the way you choose to
display the data itself
the focus what characteristics you can
add to add to draw the attention where
you want the focus of the reader to be
and forward what should the takeaway of
the visualization be how do you want the
reader to move forward after having seen
this visualization
so that's what we will be talking about
for the rest of this talk
um starting with of course the
foundation
first of all there are a couple of
different charts so there are different
plots lines plots Scatter Plots bar
charts pie charts
um
but they display different they and they
can all display information but maybe
differently so for example if you look
at these two graphs both show the exact
same data the total number of
participants and the number of trainings
offered during the year
but if you look at them which one of
them is better at showing the trend how
the numbers change during the year is
that option A the line chart or option b
the bar chart
in this case if you are interested in
the trends option A is actually better
it can immediately communicates the
Insight that you want to give the trends
whereas for option b you can still see
the same things but it takes a little
bit more effort to get that out of the
graph
and the same goes for this example let's
say that we have these two graphs again
they display the exact same data source
but which one makes it easier to
determine which investment has a
greatest share
in the first one the blocks look roughly
the same size the blue and the orange
block and the green and the red block
whereas in the second option option b it
seems pretty clear that International
stock is the biggest share of
Investments here
and this would even be more visible if
the background of the graph had been a
grid
so how do you determine the right chart
for your use case first a bit of
experimentation helps
um so try have an Insight in mind that
you want to communicate for instance the
trend and see create a couple of
different charts and see which one
conveys that a little bit better and
which one works best
but there are definitely certain types
of charts that simply work better for
certain types of data and you don't have
to reinvent the wheel yourself
so chartguide.com has I think an amazing
poster that gives an overview of what
charts work well for what data types and
this is only a fraction of it because
the whole poster is too large to show
but I wholeheartedly recommend it
um but even if you have the right chart
there are still a couple of things that
I'd like to point out because it isn't
just about picking the right chart
um one of the things for instance is you
also have to make sure that the reader
or the people who you're presenting to
is familiar with the type of chart that
you have for example charts with error
labels and confidence intervals are
typically not your friends when it comes
to explanatory data analysis
um I get it they're great explanatory
data analysis for explanatory data
analysis they give you good confidence
intervals for instance to help you
understand your data a lot better as
they give a general idea of how precise
a measurement is but it won't help the
reader understand the data
or for instance a box plot like look at
these block box plots over here they
this chart tells us a lot in terms of a
tax score for each Pokemon
um or each type of Pokemon we don't just
know the average we also get a feeling
for the consistency within the group but
as you can see there's a lot going on
here and again while when you're
exploring you have the luxury of time to
analyze this chart
the person who you're presenting to has
to immediately understand the point that
you're trying to make and box plots
aren't as common outside of exploratory
data analysis as you might think
so before you show them a visualization
this one you might have to show them
this one where you explain exactly what
a box plot represents how the
interquartile range is calculated how we
calculate the minimum whisker and
maximum whisker
um and I don't think that's going to
make their stakeholder very happy
foreign
to keep in mind is choose the data to
display carefully
so we saw that here with the population
growth example where the ranges that are
chosen to display had a huge impact on
the story
um
and although it might seem obvious the
limits and ranges can drastically change
the story as well
for instance these are again three
graphs based on the exact same data set
about booksellers but because the limit
in the first graph is different it seems
like there's a huge difference in sales
between Bookseller 1 and pixelr2 whereas
in the second graph where we we change
those limits and ranges it seems a lot
closer
and it also converges when you talk
about units in the third graph you see
here we converted the actual sales to
the percentage of cells and again
because we change the units these two
bars look a lot closer to each other
than for instance in the first or the
second image
so the choices you make on how to
display your data influence the
conclusions people will draw from the
graph as well
and I think this one is actually a very
good example as well where
um the the creator of this image tried
to discourage media from reporting
election results like in the first case
with a pie chart that only represents
the five percent of precincts that have
actually reported the results whereas if
you also report the un uh the unknown
data actually looks a lot different it
gives you a different impression
so by not choosing to display data or
even lack of data you can severely
impact the story
and as data storytellers unlike fiction
storytellers we have an obligation to
stay close to the truth
so that that being said let's move on to
our next topic the focus and for this
one I did want to do a little exercise
with you on the next slide I'm going to
show you a bunch of numbers and I want
you to as quickly as you can count the
amount of files that you see in the
image
right there we go
all right how was that you probably
could find a bunch of files but it took
you a little time because you had to
sift with your eyes through all the
numbers
however if we present this in a slightly
different way
it's probably much easier to catch all
the fives that are in this image
and there's a lot happening on the
screen at once everything is asking or
demanding for your attention and the use
of color can help you guide your
attention or Draw your attention to the
right thing
and that isn't limited to just color
here we have a simpler a similar example
with shapes in this example the eights
and the ones appear in the exact same
places but it's probably easier to shoot
swap the ones because they are more
distinctly different
when we are creating data visualization
for explanatory purposes we have
something specific in mind that we want
to communicate and if we use a
visualization that we use to get that
Insight that we had time to analyze that
probably has too much clutter in there
to focus the attention to what you want
to communicate
take this image for example this is an
image of the goal scored by each country
in the group stage of the 2020 European
championships and all the data is there
but it can be a little bit unclear what
I'm trying to show you so this is an
example where color might be helpful
in this case for example the Red Bar
draws your attention I probably want to
say something about the goals of the
Netherlands but red isn't the best
choice because it's associated with
danger and negativity so maybe we go for
green instead
uh which is more gentle and more
positive but because the bars are blue
it doesn't stand out as much
so an alternative would be to use a
color that's more representative
orange for instance which is the color
associated with the Netherlands
and we can even actively draw the
attention away from the other Bars by
giving them less noticeable colors
um and attract more attention to the bar
that we're interested in the high
scoring number of the Netherlands
and we can even add to this
visualization by giving our story a
little bit more context for instance in
this style in this case by adding a line
and some text to the chart this in this
case the line indicates the maximum
number of goals in the championship four
years earlier and by adding that line we
see that actually quite a few countries
scored more goals than the top number of
goals in the previous championship
and again we can further highlight that
again
um and you see now that this
visualization
um directs your attention to the high
scoring countries and that the
Netherlands is the highest scoring
country whereas when you compare that
with the original graph that you don't
really know what to focus on so by
changing the colors adding some text we
have transformed the first graph simply
a lot of information into a
visualization that immediately and
easily lets you draw some conclusions
such as the Netherlands was the top
scorer and there were more high scoring
teams than in the previous championship
there are of course more elements than
just text lines and colors that you can
add but these are usually enough to get
the point across
um you don't want to add too much
because then you might lose the audience
and also keep in mind that when you pick
colors to use
um the default colors in most
visualization libraries are there
because they're easy to read for the
colorblind so keep that in mind when you
change the colors as well
another element that really helps to
draw the attention is the title let's
look at this image for example it
visualizes the results of a survey of
students of class 3A who are asked
whether they like the subject or not and
this graph displays the percentage of
students who like this subject
because of the title you'll probably be
inclined to look at the first few
subjects first
whereas if we change the title slightly
your focus is to run towards the
negative and will likely go to the
bottom
and you can combine this with previous
techniques of course
such as adding color
or adding more context
to the graph itself
because of some simple design choices
your intention is guided to a completely
different part of the data in these two
graphs the one on the left is focusing
on how languages are popular while the
one on the right focuses on some
subjects are not very popular
and this brings me to my last point
forward
what is the takeaway from your
visualization ask yourself that question
ask yourself the question what actions
do you want people to take after seeing
this visualization how should their
lives change because they saw your data
and you're not just communicating it
because it's nice to know it's probably
nice to know because you want to either
convince people to do something or start
a discussion because no without an
action no matter how or discussion no
matter how amazing your chart is people
are likely going to forget it
this graph for example shares an
interesting insights but what's the
person you're presenting to supposed to
do with this Insight it's it's nice to
know but it doesn't change anything so
people will likely forget it
and the same goes for this graph it's
negative it's it's not very nice but
what do I do with this
why are we directing the focus to this
negativity here
well one way to change that is by simply
changing the title if we change it to we
need to change the way we teach them
subjects at our school it is immediately
clear why we're looking at this plot and
it's especially helpful to use active
titles that start with we need we must
should
foreign
what you'll want to do is this you want
to put your point first using an active
title then people know what they're
going to look at
then you want to present the visual data
that supports this point it helps guide
the focus and you usually once about
three elements that emphasize the focus
on where it needs to be so the title in
this case already focuses towards the
bottom the Reds and the line they all
add to the focus
and lastly you want to re-emphasize the
action to take or start a discussion
um this doesn't have to be text in your
visualization itself it can also be the
story that you tell along with the graph
but it usually doesn't hurt to put it
into words either
and with that you've converted a simple
insight to an actionable one that you
can effectively communicate simply with
having a good foundation the good chart
directing the focus and focusing on how
people must move forwards
uh data storytelling is the art of
successfully communicating about data
and hopefully my talk today has made
that a tad bit easier for you
with a good chart as a foundation for
your data titles colors and text to help
guide the focus and lastly a way to
present how to move forward or start a
discussion a reason for showing this
graph
um that is a successful communication
about data and much more successful than
simply showing the insights the
exploratory data visualization that you
got to that you made to get your Insight
in the first place
that being said thank you all for your
attention uh thank you all for having me
here today and I hope to have inspired
you to tell stories with and about your
data my name is Marisha wrinkles and
please feel free to reach out if you
have any questions or anything you want
to share you can find me on LinkedIn or
just email me directly if you want
and if there are any more questions now
I'd be happy to answer them
thank you very much
because
um we have some questions here from uh
zenell
and I'm going to show that now so that
you can see it
so the question is uh is that this
presentation is really good
so yeah so I see uh
yeah so uh one thing that I can
recommend and and I got a lot of
inspiration from okay it's a book called
uh Story Time with data
that
yeah so I can really recommend a book
called storytelling with data from uh
Coleman's power
um and she has some really interesting
talks online as well I also have a list
of reasons
yeah go ahead
uh hi hi uh Hi Marissa I'll just jump in
there I think I think is facing issues
with your questions please go on with
the with the book descriptions yeah so
um my biggest inspiration for this and
which really shifted my view I was a
data scientist and I always just thought
I got the Insight from this data
visualization so you should be able to
get it too and the person who really
changed challenged that view and told
and and I learned about explanatory data
visualization from was from the book uh
data storytelling with visualization by
Cole nussbauer and she has some really
cool Talks on YouTube as well that I
really recommend and um yeah there are
some great resources out there I can put
some links in the chat as well oh
definitely I think it'll be good as well
perhaps some on Discord if you can pop
pop in a couple of points that would be
quite useful
um there is another question by Glenn
lemon in fact there is a whole series of
discussion in chat uh because it sort of
invites a lot of subjective debate about
how you presents your data I will just
bring it up here and and we'll just have
a quick comment about that so Glenn
Lehman is asking when does telling a
story shift from sharing information to
setting a point of view
yeah I think that's a that's a really
good point so I I didn't uh put a lot of
attention to like manipulating data and
misleading data but that's of course a
choice that you can make to display your
information or your data in such a way
that it leads to a certain conclusion by
emitting things or by intentionally
misleading
um that is something that you can do but
it's something that I very much
discourage like I said I think the
difference between a data Storyteller
and a Storyteller is that
um we are we should not write fiction we
should stay true to the facts so while I
think that techniques to guide focus and
to make a point and especially to start
a discussion can be really helpful
because you have something that you want
to communicate I really strongly
discourage like misleading creating
misleading charts and those kinds of
stuff it's it's a it's a tough balance
you want to share information in the
most effective way possible for instance
by by guiding the focus but you don't
want to sell a point of view I mean
maybe you do but let's not do that yeah
yeah absolutely absolutely I agree with
you
um I'm gonna continue to go through the
very long list of questions potentially
yes that we have a question yeah so what
tool do you use to tweak the charts
um so because I I recently got into this
idea of creating more beautiful
visualizations I I would really like to
be able to make more beautiful
visualizations especially because if
you're telling a story
if it helps that if your chart is really
nice to look at because then it
automatically wraps people's attentions
more than if it's really ugly to look at
um but unfortunately I'm I'm mostly a
programmer I don't use fancy infographic
like type tools I started out with
multiple lip like I think most people
and a tool that I really like because it
also allows for some interactivity and I
think it's just really beautiful from
from like the get-go if you impose your
data is Altair the library
yeah yeah definitely I I I myself have
been playing around with plotly as well
introduces some interactivity in your
data sets if you want to interact with
your data sets uh let me see if we have
uh okay we'll take this last question
and then for for the audience members
who still have any other questions
please put them to Discord and Marisha I
can hop on there and perhaps have some
interaction over there so the last
question is uh in the election graphs
case there could be a point to avoid
inducing bias best to show both graphs
yeah I think that's actually a good
point I think in this case most of the
pie charts that were used to display
these information were used in the
context of this candidate has already
had more votes has kind of to incite the
emotion or the thought that this
candidate is going to win because they
have like a higher percentage of the
vote so far and the second chart is more
informative because it actually shows
you there are so many things left still
to count that the information you have
so far is not very relevant to draw a
conclusion on I think the second chart
actually shows you that you shouldn't be
displaying any of those charts to begin
with because the information is just
simply not telling you anything
um but yeah you could also show both
charts it also really matters what story
you tell around it like if you if you
show the first graph and you really
highlight this is just based on five
percent of the information that's
different than if it's there in terms of
information but you say oh this
candidate is clearly the front runner so
just what you say around it also matters
a lot